any questions that we get will be
answered and they'll be in a document
that we will link to the courses in
webinars page on our site and also in an
email out when all that stuff is ready
and
the ftp site URL there that compressed
link that will get you to materials the
notes for today's demonstrations and the
slides okay so we're going to talk today
about a program called quick blastp at
least that's what we call it on the web
this is a program for rapidly finding
high scoring protein matches in a large
databases my name again is Peter Cooper
that's my email address if you have any
questions about anything I'm talking
about today the credits for this of
course go to Tom Madden and Greg bore
Keane from the blast team and we're
gonna talk about some of the experiments
they did with quick blast pea in just a
few minutes so we're gonna talk about
what it is we're going to talk about why
you might want to use it or why do you
need it talk give a very brief probably
somewhat inaccurate description of the
algorithm of the procedure that quick
blast P uses but enough to so you can
sort of understand what it does well
look at some of the experiments that Tom
did looking at results from quick blast
being comparing them to ordinary blast
and then we'll talk about how do you get
the quick blast P on the website and
also how to use a standalone binary that
you can get to now as a demonstration
and then we'll hope to do some things
live on the web on the command line so
what is quic plus P this is a faster
alternative for ordinary protein protein
blast uses especially pre indexed
database we'll talk about that more in a
few minutes it's designed for rapid
matching of queries and very similar
database sequences about 97% of database
sequences it was 70% or more identity
the query are found and about 98% with
the 80% or more didn't ADA query or
found this is compared to what you would
get with ordinary blast P so it's less
sensitive why do we need this anyway and
there's a number of challenges that are
really a result of the advent of
high-throughput sequencing and rapid
processing of genomes the default blast
database which is called NR now contains
about 141 million sequences actually
more than that and 51 billion letters
and it's doubling time is about two
years so next year at this time it
should be over a hundred million letters
and many of you have probably
experienced the fact that ordinary
protein blast searches is for taking
longer than they used to if you have a
highly conserved or highly represented
protein that means one that's there are
lots of copies of in the database are
variations of it search like that can
take now up to a few minutes and of
course modern Hydra projects are
generating a lot of data at the same
time they have a need to analyze a lot
of their protein coding regions and
really what you're trying to do in those
cases you have a meta genomic sequence
or a genome or something like that
you're trying to find the strong matches
in the database because many of those
proteins will have close matches so all
this means that we need a process that
will let you quickly identify strong
matches to a set of query sequences
sensitivity in this case is less
important in most cases so this is a
very oversimplified description of what
the quick blastp does the first part of
the quick blastp search uses an
alignment free method and basically it
makes an index of the fibers of the
database and the query sequences and
basically looks them up in memory to
find candidate matches which have good K
more content compatibility the second
part is to take those candidate matches
and do a blast alignment with them and
so doing that means you get to standard
blast P alignments and statistics the
first part finding your matches uses
that alignment free method so I'll just
go over some results that Tom in the
Blass group presented at the NIH
research festival recently and they
basically are the kinds of things we're
talking about where they looked at a
proteome from Shigella Flexner i 4790
nine proteins from that genome this is a
whole genome shotgun assembly project
and another kind of proteome this is
from a transcriptome shotgun assembly
project this is for a tick and below my
sculpt them and 4246 proteins and
basically they did searches comparing
those against an AR and they got some
information that's very useful out of
that about how blastp and
Espie perform people has please a name
for the standalone program that
corresponds to quick blasts
so for blastp these two projects that
Shigella took ten hours and for an
Bellomo they took 18 hours in the
corresponding cases blastp quick blastp
the faster method reduces those times by
tremendous amount so the speed up for
the Shigella was about 13 times faster
for the ambulance cope them was about 20
times faster so obviously this is a huge
improvement in the speed at which you
can analyze set of proteins this is
looking at the number of hits found at
various % identities notice it as you go
down in percent identity cable SP or
quick blast P does a little bit worse
compared to blast B and so that little
circle I have there is the 65 percent
identity point and that's a good point
to say you know below that % I did any
quick blast P is not as effective and
for this particular set of proteins it's
not quite as dramatic as it is for the
next set these are the ones from the
tick so you see that the departure Li
quickly after sit below 65 percent any
this has to do with basically what kinds
of proteins are in the database and how
closely related they are to the set of
proteins we're working with so you see
less saturation of the blastp results
with tic proteins and you deal with this
yellow proteins another way of looking
at this is looking at the number of
missed hits compared to blastp with a 65
percent identity cutoff and without one
and so you see fewer missed hits this is
the column here for zero miss hits over
here there's a slight difference in the
65 percent bar there it's quite a bit
more difference if you look at that for
the tick proteins so the takeaway
message from this is that this works
well but probably is only limited to
things that are better than 65 percent
I didn't eat which is fine if what
you're trying to do is to find what
protein is this in the database so how
can you run quick blast P or the
standalone version cable Aspie smart
blast which was been
around for a number of years actually
uses a quick plus B algorithm already
and has for several years quick blast P
is now on the protein protein blast page
as a program choice I'll show you that
in a minute
and cable SP is available as a
standalone demonstration package on the
Plast FTP area and I'll show you how to
get to that too so in terms of the live
by a website smart blast which is linked
directly to the blast homepage and is
also available and from your results
does use the quick blast P algorithm by
the way if you want to know more about
smart blast we did do a webinar on that
a while back and that link there will
take you to our YouTube channel and you
can take a look at that webinar this is
the standard protein protein blast page
and you can see that one of the program
selection choices is now and it's got
the new icon there next to it on the
bottom here is quick blast P blast P is
a default but you can change this to
quick blast P to run quick blast P right
now this is only available for the in
our database and that's because it
requires a special index of those five
murders of the database in order to run
it so we'd have to index the other
databases in order to make them work
with quick blast P you can also download
a linux package for this quick blast
tar.gz which is available in the demo
area of the blast FTP area there's a
readme there and there's the tarball
with quick blast P and the indexing
program as well and if you get that
readme it tells you exactly how to
download and install this it comes with
several different programs and I'll talk
about what those are directly this right
now is only available for Linux so
what's in there you get K blast P which
is the corresponding standalone version
of quick blast it does the first part in
the second part of the blast search it's
a search program it has very similar
options to blast P there's the make K
blast index this is the program that
makes the database index of the fibers
so it requires a formatted protein
databases input
it's going to add some additional
indices for the initial alignment
research the package also comes with the
update plasti B Perl script that's for
downloading your blast databases and
there's also a sort of a script in there
that does that's called cat volumes SSH
what it does is it basically loads a
blast database volumes into memory you
can sort of get a hot start on your
blast search that speeds up the search
if you have a large database the way
this is written right now is it
specifies the refseq protein database
but you can modify it to use other
databases so just a couple of things to
think about we've already sort of said
this but I'll just want to remind you
again quick blast P rapidly finds
closely related proteins and so I would
say that it's basically not terribly
useful if your matches are below about
65 percent identity we're going to show
you an example of that in a few minutes
it shines if you're doing batches of
queries and so that's sort of the idea
behind it is through analyzing a large
number of protein sequences or a smaller
number on the web it's still several of
them the standalone program for this to
work it requires at the blast database
plus the indices be able to be
completely loaded into the RAM and just
sort of a note if you're thinking about
the default protein database which of
course is very large in our database
plus these indices require between 200
to 250 gigabytes of RAM the index files
for cable SP occupy more than half of
this total so you need a machine with
lots of available RAM in order to do
this effectively okay so I'm gonna leave
the slideshow now and do a couple of
demos one on the web show you what
happens when you do protein blast and
quick blast P with the same set of
proteins in the same settings I'm going
to take five proteins from it Shigella
flex type rhodium that I talked about a
few minutes ago and then I'll show you
some a problem with sensitivity that
it's one we already talked about but
just so you can see what it looks like I
took some of those tic proteins which
have less good matches in the database
and you can see what happens with when
you get below about
I did any and then we're going to go
over to the command line and do some
cable SP searches with 33 proteins from
a plasmid from Serratia liqui faison's
I'm gonna do two things here we're gonna
use the blast interface here let me knit
get a little bit bigger so we can see it
and I'm going to use these notes these
are the notes for my demos and they're
available by the way on that FTP site so
if you ever want to do these things
again and the the our IDs are have been
preserved so the links to the searches
will work so I'm just going to put that
in your face for a moment and I'm going
to go ahead and just show you the speed
up hopefully with these five should yell
out proteins so I'm gonna select them
here I've got them in my little notepad
here copy them and I'm gonna go over to
the protein blast search page here and
paste them in so they're ready to go and
now by default the settings here to run
blast peace what I'm going to do is I'm
going to start that blastp search
running I'm going to open my results in
a new tab here and I'm just going to
change a couple things I'm going to set
this to get 500 hits just a couple of
things that people would typically want
to do here and set the e-value cutoff to
ten to the minus six and let me go ahead
and start that running so it's loading
in this tab over here and this is my
blastp search let's go back I'm going
back here and now I'm going to change
this to quick blast P and it changed my
max target sequences I'll go ahead and
set those to 500 again so it's exactly
the same as the settings we use for last
P and I'm going to go ahead and run that
now this is where it gets interesting
let's hope this works so what we can
basically do is watch the time send
submission and my experience with this
is it takes about 10 seconds let's see
if that's true yeah pretty much
it takes about 10 seconds
while meanwhile the blastp search is
still running and with an organism like
Shigella there are lots and lots of
proteins in the database that are very
similar to the ones we're working with
and so this search worked pretty well
you can go through here and look at your
results which one of your query
sequences got lots of hits yeah here's
one that didn't get a lot of hits so if
we look at the scores down here
I hit a Shigella protein it's got a
pretty good coverage and it's 100%
identical I ate the same protein
essentially it warns me about that it
says your search has less than 10
matches you may want to run this search
with blastp in this particular case
though this is probably the right answer
but you can go back and try it again I'm
going to show you a case now where the
result you get with the quick blast P is
probably not the right answer
so my by the way my blastp results did
come in for this so I can take a look at
the 98th one here and really I did get
one other hit but it's a fairly weaker
one so this one's probably okay there is
a hit at 51% identity that again with
blastp that I don't get with the quick
blast now let me show you another
example where you have to watch out so
and that's when you will get down into
low press identities and this is from
the am Bellomo sculpt um transcriptome
so I'll get there quick blast P results
here and I'm just going to open that
into one of these tabs here
so these were for proteins I can just
show you what they work here so I just
got those from the transcriptome and I
ran the blast search with them first one
looks fine
lots of good matches just let me show
you this last protein so it finds one
hit and notice that my % identity is
very low 27%
so this is something that I just
basically wouldn't want to think about
in terms of using this as a result
because it's too low for a quick blast P
to be useful just to show you the
difference I'm going to go ahead and
load the blast P results so you can see
what happens with those I copy that I'll
paste it in the same window
so let's look at that last protein again
remember this protein found that match
in cable SP was one match actually this
finds lots of good matches that are
significant when you're using blast P so
just be careful when you're looking
looking at a low person identity you
don't really want to be using on the
quick Class B but it works great if your
sequences are very similar to each other
okay further they have lots of examples
of themselves in the databases maybe
another way of putting that ok the next
thing I want to do is to go and to show
you the standalone package and if you go
to the notes here it's got the setup
commands and everything and I've already
done those so I downloaded quick lesbi I
untied it and I downloaded the Swiss Pro
database because that's a small database
and we can run searches fairly fast this
is the command that you would use to
index your Swiss Pro database and I'm
not going to run that for you live
because it takes a couple of minutes and
that's kind of a long pause so let's go
ahead and we're going to do a search and
just as a bonus example I'm going to
show you how to get a uz length to get
the protein sequences for this Serratia
plasmid so let me just put that command
and this just basically says I'm going
to get the accession of that plasmid
from the nucleotide database I'm going
to go to the protein database and fetch
the fast a proteins for this so let's do
that first and I'm going to go over here
to a command window here okay so let's
run that that shouldn't take but a few
seconds ok so just let's just make sure
that that really worked so I have a
bunch of proteins from this ratio
liquidations plasmid and now I've got a
couple of blasts command lines here one
for K blast P and one for blast P and
I'm going to run them under the UNIX
command time so we can see how long they
take so here's cave last peek man
and this command-line it wrapped a
little bit but that's okay this is this
is really the options are no different
than they would be for ordinary blastp
so I've selected my database Swiss proud
here's my query which is that fast a
file I've set an e-value cutoff of ten
to the minus six and I'm using one of
the tab delimited output formats output
format seven and then I'm just gonna
make an output file here so time is
going to tell me how long it took to run
this and it usually takes about a little
bit under ten seconds let's see how it
goes and of course how long it takes is
going to depend a lot upon the machine
you're using and what's going on on that
machine and things like that so the real
time here was about nine seconds and
let's make sure that that wasn't a trick
and we just we didn't get anything maybe
we got nothing so let's check it so
let's go let's look at that output file
so we got lots and lots of stuff here
those dead limited format these hit lots
of Swiss Road Records there's a big file
there and I'll go ahead and start the
blastp running same query same
command-line basically but a different
program and that will run for a little
while so while we're doing that I'll go
back out to the slides and just point
out where you can get some additional
information about blast and other parts
of NCBI as well so let's go ahead and
run that so just a reminder the blast
homepage is there it has its own special
URL blast at NCBI NLM that NIH took of
and there's a little help link at the
top that takes you to a nice page that
has lots of documentation available
there and there's a newsfeed there's
also a mailing list you can subscribe to
military the list how do I get to that
in a minute
also to reminder that Tao and I sit on
the blast help email alias and you can
write to us anytime you have a question
about blast as a I often like to say
it's a good idea to bring send us your
our ID if you have a problem with a
plastered so we can see what happened
digital useful links here there is a
blast help book on the bookshelf that
has
different parts to it including how to
set up blast the command-line standalone
manual that's how to get to the mailman
list for blasts and outs and there's
some general things that you should know
about we have a blog NCBI insights we
have a YouTube channel we also have a
Support Center this is a place where you
can go if you have a question you can go
there and you might be able to find the
answer to your question if you can't
find the answer you can send us an email
and that can be about blasts or any of
the other NCBI services there's also a
set of fact sheets on our FTP site many
of them are about blast how is the major
contributor to that so there are lots of
things there about how to set up last so
let me let's escape from here real quick
and see if that finished no it's still
running you can check back in in a few
minutes nope just finished though it
took about two minutes to run that okay
so that's pretty much all I had to talk
about today so I'll throw it open for
questions if anybody has any questions
if you have a question about the webinar
program in general please write the
webinars webinars at NCBI
NLM NIH
govt thanks everybody for coming and
we'll see you next time
you